I am so excited, because these was the last pair of Air Pods that they had in the store this is just a few days ago
But today [was] the day they were in the store december 19th
2016 I've made a video on YouTube saying "I got my Air Pods!"
about three days ago
February 18th
2017 I made a video talking about air pods straps. that you put on your air Pod so you wont  lose them
I'm sure many of you have been waiting patiently for this video
When will ijustine lose her air pods and guess what I made it?
how many days?
64 days
The Irony is I just made a few days ago that video talking about how I haven't lost them and I was so excited
The Air Pods strap, which I never even actually end up using the strap
There's no good story about how I lost them I didn't just lose the air pods that go into my ear
I lost the entire case
my sister was like where did you lose them and I said well if I knew where I lost them they wouldn't be lost
They would be found. but they're not they are not found their lost. but here is the bad news
I went to reorder myself a pair of Air Pods
And they said that it would take at least six weeks to ship so apparently the Air Pods are still kind of difficult to get
I'm fake crying. [I] [wasn't] [even] like a good fake cry. That was just dramatic
I'm sure I'm gonna hear it all in the comments, The Air Pods are stupid
This is what Apple wants they want you to lose them
But the fact that I have actually have kept them that long is kind of incredible
And I didn't mean I don't even have good story about it. I'm pretty sure I just left them in the hotel room
I just got back from vacation, vacation vlogs coming up tomorrow. I just thought that I would address
What happened because I talked about it on Twitter
And I didn't really go to detail and everyone wanted to hear the story
of how I lost the Air Pods
There's no good story at all, absolutely no good story
but this gif is probably one of my most favorite things I've ever seen on the event
I might of left them at the pool or the beach, I don't know if I knew they would not be lost
And people who end up seeing Air Pods out and about. They don't know what they are
They is assuming that it's dental floss. So who's going to be like wow?
I think I'm going to save this dental  floss for you because you probably are going to come back to the hotel or to the Pool to get it. You're not
Whats in here Justine?
...My second pair of Air Pods,
not gonna lie that hit that I just did on my head that hurt a lot because I hit the bridge of my nose
I'm not happy about this. It's not like this is something that I'm excited about wasting money on because I couldn't wait six weeks
I travel a lot. This is basically the only thing that I use now for headphones, and I can't believe that
I actually like them so much that
I already am not sure how to live without them
Some of my favorite comments on the previous video that I made about the Air Pods Straps
Why dont you just keep the ones that came with the iPhone,
The ones that have the wires the earbuds not the air pods because essentially you're just making yourself
New here, but I know trust me,
I've heard it all. I know this is me
here they are, fresh, new
They still dont have a smell, I should put like if found tweet me if you want to put like this is not dental floss
please returned to owner. I'd appreciate it. I managed to get these in the airport on ebay basically
Overnight shipping, so I haven't had to go a day without them are you spoiled Justine? Are you Spoi..YES
Yes I am but guess what these are the things that I choose to waste my money on it is my money to waste
I'm not proud of it feel free to hate all you want in the comments
I know I know I've heard it all before I've read it all before nothing
You can say to sway my opinion of how I feel about the things that I shouldn't do in my life, okay?
[am] I having a mental breakdown perhaps? I am do you want to talk about it?
I'm clearly talking about it right now another thing that I would like to discuss the fact that they removed Find my Airpods
Airport find my Air Pod feature from the IOS Beta [this] [is] something is going to be very important
Apple please put it back put [it] back
I need to know where they are well also make it so that I'm able to find these on GPS like [fly] my eyes 101
Don't weigh exactly where it is all time is it on my body is it near my body is it in my body?
I need to know where are
My Air Pods. Because  I don't want to lose them again. I need to make myself a little sticky note
I've got a label maker and I'm going to get to labeling. Well. Thank you guys for watching
I hope you bring you a better joyful video tomorrow filled with lots of Joy
Lots of joy, and just know that at a time was bad video being filmed my Air Pods are still
in my possession, so I hope to somebody finds them and they
Can give them a new home and love them the way that I did for two months
See you later
It's the only thing that I want to talk about, ive wanted to show it to you, ive wanted to post it on instagram, post it on snapchat
Ive wanted to even post it on Facebook
So I flip over and I see 94 95 and I'm like what ridiculous. That's an absolute waste of money
I Need it
The fact is this cup sits on my head, its very.